how's it going bros my name is beautify
and welcome to the future alright let's
enter the job simulator here we go oh my
god i got hands
what KNG oh I gotta wash my hands right
make them nice and moist
this sound is nailing you to me did I
wash myself got a shower this is how
hopeless people shower I saw you once
I'll be our water tastes so dicey
can I drink the stove disco alright
holy [ __ ] I will start by making some
breakfast turn on the grill and let's
get dried all right let's turn on the
rail okay even though humans spend the
entire night in a state of low power
consumption they still shouting get it
all right that's good bacon and eggs how
are you oh my god what the [ __ ] this is
freaking me out
all right okay let's cook the bacon
functioning pretty well don't knock the
[ __ ] out the students on the plate then
you can ring the bell to send it down to
the restaurant yeah I'll send it out all
right all right I got some egg coming up
I'll get some some bacon we got to put
it on a plate
what is this a [ __ ] restaurant done
enjoy yeah [ __ ] man [ __ ]
oh you've got another one right what is
this smoothie what is this the [ __ ]
fruit place who the [ __ ] order a
smoothie and I struck down [ __ ] job
my God why are you looking at me
Oh God some fight Hey go back to work I
[ __ ] your mom she was a widescreen if
you know what I mean ha ha all right
let's make a smoothie I feel good I feel
good about this job all right where's
the blender okay let's
blender oh [ __ ] that's [ __ ] cool
oh my god can I blend my face oh my god
should i do impress o3 man where am I
but Judy there put some carrot and let's
put some all right let's put that in
there as well and there we go this is
[ __ ] offset by the best restaurant
place and I wanted a smoothie hey yours
take my [ __ ] smoothie and take your
[ __ ] [ __ ] with it god dammit
someone work alrighty see Yuri alright
come on I got a job to do [ __ ] man be
the water there it is put it on the
[ __ ] stove oh Jesus Christ it's hard
meeting it's hard being a hard-working
man it's not run flour add some extra
flavor about that this is I can do
everything all right we got some purpose
Oh foxy yeah Madison school talk about a
damn business here would you eat this
would you eat this take a [ __ ] job I
wish I could just go back to YouTube
play [ __ ] games all day
yeah that's ready to go oh god it's a
good one let's add that you got to make
grandma soup it's called the little
[ __ ] thing of better
yeah I should do it I'd open extra spice
my favorite who's fighting sucks go to
my next that's right there yes ah yes
sir dick [ __ ] enjoy it [ __ ]
your ass'll is might learn a bit
tomorrow but it's all going to be worth
it Cubans were through to this is he
sandwich chef or safe
alright sandwich time yes or take rock
with that Fox again this is going to be
one [ __ ] nice sandwich right so
cookie is going to be the greatest
[ __ ] sandwich of all time the
focusing amateurs I can't catch it
god dammit [ __ ] yeah so let's not forget
the other I call it the ideal tower hey
what's a sandwich that was delicious
Oh computing your [ __ ] face you crazy
son of a [ __ ]
that looks just like a penis oh [ __ ]
what you getting some walleye in my food
I call this one did you bag it up and
eat it
what's your [ __ ] problem god damn it
I hate my life go to end it I'm going to
end it I'm going to end my son you don't
even subscribe alright well thank you
folks for watching this video if you
want more virtual reality videos like
this one leave a like and as always
virtual brofist
[ __ ] you why Hey